okay guys this is their game called
striking pains that's thethat's I don't
know anything about this partner
preference I'm going for the fam you
know Oh a fan did your chili always
light on headlights eyes the bedroom
window falling strip you could feel
Isabel awakened next year she yawns
charging her limps I fed the quantity of
the better skin presses against mine I
don't know Wow all right now it's very
nice sweet and it's acted before she
lies that kiss on your shoulder well
that's just magical
good morning laughs yeah beat pad across
the room Mayon been for a little while
there's some good message from you tell
your best friend that don't associate
media not mi suggest any polar stuff I
bet it's harder than you remember you
join Isabel oh she just her work okay
I had beautiful hey you feeling I'm like
a you sure you're not liking great no
I'm fine
I just concerned she was your eyes it's
not you sure did it coughing uh make you
on and I bought the kettle put some
sugar grant your peas er at your
favorite the one with an obscure oh I
don't get it I'm looking for at that
height damn every day remember to make
the bucking I've got blood gender your
favorite our fat friend just allows me
to correct you I heard a laugh what time
should I get there so thirty little Brit
on her smiles to see you happy two years
my love the coffee you want to drink up
a part of towers at the saw the warmth
idea of it being inside you what brow
when your shirt his belt won't come be
pour it down the sink
perfect hey baby
nice to be here with you thank you for
organizing this saddle up you ever need
and today I like to keep it that way set
up in the kitchen watching day two I
think that a grip view it is for her the
ready make sure it's shank it can't just
hit the fat blob yes yeah let's get
pasta bro
yes perfect she smiles please y'all
deserve her what you saying are you
going to what how was your day today see
you see intimacy okay can't keep it up
gets bigger food he push it on the plate
doesn't mean for smaller target mm-hmm
takes a slice of brass and high-pressure
grant brings to your mouth okay you
gotta eat this that makes you say he
hands out thinking about the food you
had a lack of food or the browser for
this MA the field of the fatty fish
pressing together when he sit down
that's it oh my god she's crying I can't
do this grab her bag excess darshan
lives you know surprisingly she okay she
always was like that hey yeah Dan what's
kind of baby then I was her for you
while you okay and not really hey like
thought so be around tonight summits of
food you can tell me he was cub round
have a good day it's how the front door
closing did he fall asleep again it
can't be seven where I hear you know I'm
packing the groceries the fridge swims
he's dying he's dying half-empty
capsicum what is that basically we had a
fee on actually done it today a city but
it's bail on it we loved her say she
made quiet blah blah and he stopped he
doing his Chester put the base X I
perturb Reggie a she wants him now and I
can I'm gonna have myself is that okay
and he's eating he's eating hey hey hey
you sent hepatitis gone there's a spot
of fast there's a word about you that
looks convinced in a while since
everyone's seen you would answer mine
not found great it's my birthday should
come where is that with ginger oh my god
yeah hey Canada
oh my God look at those food that I
can't eat
they can't eat this I got the ceiling
yeah I'm dead Brown me gettin gettin
skinny um I get so sad you got to get
out of here Brown what
is what's in your head serving Allah
beautiful Wow they got bad
she's perfect well you same for my
little pen face my hair bow my head back
that's it going cries a bridge over
weeks I've been smoking again hope to
die what's the rush that on
that's getting at getting skinnier
let's get that lattice brow
yeah yeah yeah eyebrow yeah now Dan
Brown
we're again
against travel times treacherous I'm in
that car
oh my god fell asleep
howsoever like
what is that
I try to hate this I'm trying to aid
this fed
right I go
dad - Trevor like I'm too skinny again
I'm a cat they got too skinny
I know doctor guys don't be too skinny
you know what I bet like a bar yeah I
don't wanna make bones in scan okay max
I'll die with my ChaCha's okay bye